okay great uh welcome back uh so we'll
start with some Garrett from Berkeley
who will uh
um tell us about Quantum classical
correlation classical relations thanks
for the introduction thanks uh thanks
for coming to the talk
um so yeah I'm going to be talking about
what we've been up to for the last uh
year or so uh this has been working
collaboration with uh Zach Weinstein a
PhD student here and uhud
um and is written about in these two
papers
um so this is a talk that's in some
sense about
um the the limitations of what we can do
with quantum computers uh in
experimental in in physics experiments
so the basic question is going to be
whether we can observe the effects that
lots of measurements have on a Quantum
system
and this has uh interesting connections
that I'll discuss two problems in random
circuit sampling
so of course you know the reason we're
here is because we have some new
platforms to play with we have you know
superconducting quantum computers we
have maybe slightly more traditional
Quantum simulators based on optical
lattices
um and yeah the feature that we have
access to in these in these systems that
I'll be focusing on is that we now have
fine control over the measurement
process and so the question is what can
we do with this so of course a strong
motivation for developing find control
over the measurement process is that
it's going to be necessary for error
correction
um in the many body physics context
um this this control has recently
allowed some pretty amazing experiments
on the preparation of many body
topological States
um which which is required measurements
and then condition conditional unitary
operations
um performed after them
um so
I'm going to be talking about
um
measurements not necessarily with the
goal of creating a particular state or
before or performing a particular
computation
um but just the basic effects that
measurements can have on a many body
Quantum state
so one um context in which
this problem is arisen
is random circuit sampling so I probably
don't need to tell any of you about the
details of the Google experiment for a
few years ago where they declared a
Quantum Supremacy
um so the problem here was to take some
array of qubits evolve them under some
unitary circuit and then having evolved
them to measure all of the qubits uh and
then the point is that for a
sufficiently deep circuit uh the it's
very hard to sample for sample this
distribution of measurement outcomes on
a classical computer
foreign
so it turns out that this uh random
circuit sampling problem or the hardness
of random circuit sampling is dual to a
quite what appears to be a quite
different problem which I'll draw uh
illustrate with a very similar image to
highlight the connection uh and this
problem is related to what we call the
measurement inducing tanglement
transition
so the measurement you just entanglement
transition it doesn't involve measuring
all of the qubits you ask a slightly
different question you ask okay given
that I've prepared some complicated mini
body state with my unitary circuit and
I've measured maybe all of the qubit
this is one particular probe you can use
you could then ask given that I've
measured all of these all of these
qubits except maybe two of them can you
tell me about the effect that these
measurements have had on the unmeasured
qubits
so you'd be interested not in measuring
all the qubits but measuring say orbit 2
and trying to say something about the
properties of this post measurement
density Matrix so this row M indicates
that the density Matrix of this qubit is
conditioned on these early outcomes
so in the context of random circuit
sampling it was shown uh a few years ago
now
um although the PRX appear quite
recently uh the the in this context the
sampling from the from this distribution
becomes hard Beyond some critical depth
of your circuit
so this transition in the hardness of
sampling is in fact dual to
um the statement that the post
measurement density Matrix here is
entangled with the other well sorry this
qubit here is entangled with the other
unmeasured qubit
so in this context it was referred to as
a teleportation transition
um so what I'm going to be so on this
hand on on this side you say well okay
there's some Quantum advantage in
sampling once you get Beyond some
critical depth on this side actually
it'll turn out that if you play instead
of the game of trying to study the
effect of measurements on this density
Matrix you run into a problem that we
call the post-selection problem
so okay this brief outline of this talk
is going to be I'll talk a bit about
what the post selection problem is I'll
talk about how you can mitigate it by
rethinking the way you do the experiment
and then I'll talk about some
applications
of the scheme I describe
okay so the game is how do we say
something about row M
so let's say we performed uh M
measurements so m in this case with
maybe the N minus 2 where n is the
number of qubits when we perform these
measurements we get some string of
outcomes
so normally when we do an experiment
when we want to characterize a Quantum
State what we do is we measure an
observable
um so a standard way to characterize a
Quantum state is of course using an
expectation value
so in this context you might say okay
well I should prepare om I should
measure row M I'll get some eigenvalue
of the power easy operator and then as
you as we do in all standard experiments
we should just average this result the
problem is that we can't do this
the reason we can't do this is that in
order to determine a conditional
expectation value like this in order to
say something about the States you
create through measurement you have to
prepare that state multiple times
but of course if row M was prepared by a
large number of measurements the
probability that you end up preparing
the state again is exponentially smaller
than the system size
so you quickly find yourself in a
situation where it's just impossible to
characterize these post measurement
states by any standard means
a kind of a side for the computer
scientists in the audience so the
post-election problem is um there's a
problem for experimental physics but
it's hinting towards a kind of
fundamental limitation of what we can
and can't do with quantum computers so
the point here the point with the point
of view papers was to show that if you
could force the measurement outcomes you
wanted if you could post-select that for
particular measurement outcomes quantum
computers would in fact be much more
powerful
turning that around
um we can say that the randomness of the
quantum measurement process when we're
trying to you know study a mini body
Quantum state or when we're trying to
design an algorithm is actually a
fundamental limitation
so yeah so the question I'm going to be
addressing is you know given the
randomness of the measurement outcomes
given that we cannot choose the outcome
the nature gives us how can we
characterize the post measurement States
so let's think about uh some toy example
that we're all familiar with so let's
say that we have two experimentalists
Alice and Bob and they share a bell pair
like up up plus down down
so one of our experimentalists Alice
measures their spin let's say Alice
finds up
at this stage Bob does not know the
state of his spin well Bob's qubit is in
maximally mixed state as far as he's
concerned
but now if Alice tells Bob the outcomes
essay by sending a postcard with the um
outcome listed on it uh Bob given this
classical information knows the out
knows the state of his qubit another way
of saying this is that provided Bob uses
Alice's measurement outcome Bob can Bob
knows the outcome that his measurement
will have with certainty
so this is just telling us that in a in
an experiment studying the effects of
measurements you have to use the
measurement outcome somehow
so okay what do we do
so we prepare our state of Interest
through using a Quantum circuit maybe
it's a ground state there are many
different possibilities here
I'm drawing a circuit to make it look
more familiar
um so in each run of the experiment
which I'll label R what we do is we
observe some set of outcomes we're never
going to see this set of outcomes again
the probability that we see this set of
outcomes again is exponentially smaller
than the system size or in the number of
measurements performed
so you know in doing this we've created
our post measurement state
and then we measure we measure this
state we measure this state we find some
outcome we call this outcome ZR plus or
minus one just one of the eigenvalues of
the observable that we chose to measure
so the question then is okay as we as
we're used to in experiments we're going
to have to do some kind of average
so the question is given these results
which you'd hope would were telling us
something about the effects that the
measurements had on the quantum state
um should we just average them and the
point isn't that no we can't just
average them the regime we can't average
them is that averaging the averaging the
result of our experiment this is e
um has essentially the effect of of uh
converting our measurement outcomes into
dephasing events like performing a
measurement and not using the outcome is
equivalent to a dephasing event
so one way of thinking about this is
just by you know unwrapping this simple
thing ZR so ZR which is plus or minus
one we can think of this as the
expectation value that we'd want but
which we can't get because they're
because of the need to post select
we can think of it as this expectation
value we want plus some noise which is
mean zero
now when we perform this average what
we're doing is we're washing out this
noise as we wanted to but the problem is
we're also losing information on the
variations of this expectation value
Over The Ensemble of measurement
outcomes
so we're losing information we're losing
the information that we wanted to get
um at the same time as washing out the
fluctuations we wanted to remove
so a way to you know preserve this
information
um well there's a lot of freedom here a
way to preserve this information is to
just say well each run of the experiment
what I'll do is I'll take this number ZR
I'll pick a number I'll pick another
number wmr I'm not going to tell you
what wmr is yet so I just picked some
number and I perform this weighted
average so this weighted average is now
in printable sensitive to the expect the
conditional expectation values of the
parallel easy operator that I could use
to characterize the effects of
measurements
so if we do this you indeed get away
from this um
in in some sense you get away from the
post-election problem if you demand that
the the variance of this object that
you're averaging is you know worst
polynomial in M you can now do your
experiment in a time that is polynomial
in the number of measurements you
perform
um but the problem is is this is uh
there's quite a lot of freedom here so
if you're coming at this from the
perspective you're wanting to do an
experiment and study the effect the
measurements have in a state so far what
I've told you is you should just pick a
number pick a number wmr and um this
should get away from the post-election
problem the problem is that you've I
know there's no longer a post-selection
problem there's no longer a barrier to
looking for structure in the Ensemble of
post measurement States
um but the result you've got clearly
doesn't have much to do with the quantum
state it depends very sensitively on
these weights you've chosen
so just uh so what I'm saying here is
that we just have too much freedom
um so just reviewing what I was just
saying we have some weights we have some
outcomes we average when we average we
get rid of these fluctuations we're left
with this so the question is really if
we um
want to study the effects of
measurements we have to choose choose a
choose a nice way to use the data so one
possible Choice which I'll
deviate from in a moment but at least
the choice we settled on last summer was
to say okay what if we choose these
weights to be our theoretical estimates
for what these post measurement
expectation value should be so this now
gets you to a situation that's not too
unlike cross-entropy benchmarking in the
context of random circuit sampling with
a caveat that these local objects
um so if we did if we choose our weights
in this way then instead of
uh you know some completely arbitrary uh
weighted average of our experimental
data what we end up with is the cross
correlation between Theory and
experiment so this is what's observable
so this cross correlation which we call
the quantum class Quantum classical
cross-correlation is an observable
signature of the effects of measurement
and I should add that this um this is
not all a fantasy this kind of scheme is
actually developed independently and
then implemented in this experiment uh
by Google back in March where they
studied measurement-induced criticality
and of course what you could do you
could take this cross-correlation
between your expectation and what the
experiment's actually giving you and you
can compare that with just your
theoretical estimate or the classical
classical cross-correlation
okay so the um
kind of experiment that I'm describing
here now
is you take your Quantum simulator
you perform your measurements you get
your post measurement density Matrix and
you measure this
you feed these measurement outcomes into
a classical computer here represented by
this abacus
from the Abacus you extract your post
measurement expectation value your you
know your classical estimate for the
Post measurement expectation value this
could be any kind of classical
simulation it could be tensor networks
it could be Quantum Monte Carlo if
you're looking at Ground States
it could be a free family on simulation
um you combine these two things and this
gives you your Quantum classical
cross-correlation and of course also the
classical classical object
okay so this is kind of where we were a
few months ago now
um I should also yeah I should add that
this scheme only requires classical post
processing so this is a realistic
experiment you can perform without
having any adaptive elements in your
Quantum circuit
um but of course the problem that I've
hinted at already is that the way we
construct these cross-correlation is
completely arbitrary
um and kind of another way of saying
this is that our experimental result is
sensitive to our Theory so in what sense
can we call this setup a um a probe of
our post measurement Quantum States if
we change the way we simulate the system
we change our result and in this sense
you could
um or you could massage your theory to
get a better experimental result and
this is not not an ideal situation
so okay well the first half of this talk
is really about is um you know can we
learn something about Theory independent
quantities can we learn something about
the effects that measurements have on a
Quantum system without corrupting the
signal with our choice of how to model
the system
um so the there's a few steps towards
this
um and the okay what I'm going to build
up to over the next few slides is to
show how you can actually determine or
bound
um the average of the entanglement
entropies of these post measurement
States using a scheme like the one I've
just described the first step towards
this is to generalize
um a scheme people often call classical
Shadows that was developed a few years
ago now
um by these two groups
so we have a different density Matrix
every run of our experiment
what we'll do we can imagine applying
some random unitary it could be how
random it could be from the Clipper
group
I should stress this isn't all this
isn't specific to single qubits but I'll
talk about it in that language
so we okay we take our density we take
our local density Matrix we scramble the
information locally and then what we do
is we measure we measure we get a result
ZR now what we then do is you construct
this kind of funny looking object called
a shadow this uh this is not a valid
density Matrix I have to stress
um but it has the property that on
averaging it becomes a density Matrix so
this thing called a shadow is just
defined such that if we averaged if we
were able to average over these
unitaries and over these measurement
results
um then we would be able to wash out
this fluctuation and be left with the
true density Matrix so the reason I'm
writing it in this way is to draw an
analogy we thought I was describing a
moment ago in the context of washing out
the fluctuations in The observed
eigenvalue in an experiment
okay so now we can play a similar game
to before
so
now we can take these Shadows we can
multiply them by some uh some you know
now matrices we choose getting back to a
similar problem to before and on
averaging in this way we get to some
info some information on The Ensemble of
post measurement density matrices
the question is how should we choose WM
so one quantity that you know many of us
are interested in in characterizing
anybody characterizing Quantum States is
the entanglement entropy
so I'll now over the next couple of
slides show you how using a cross
correlation between Theory and
experiment you can bound the true
average entanglement entropy of your
Quantum system
so what you could do is you could choose
this Matrix these Matrix valued weights
to be minus log row CM one way of you
know one way of thinking about this for
those who are familiar with it is this
is the entanglement hamiltonian so
you're taking the entanglement
hamiltonian
and what you'll do is you'll take the
entanglement hamiltonian multiply it by
this Shadow you were attracted in your
experiment on averaging you'll find this
funny looking object which still clearly
depends very sensitively on how you've
chosen to model the system model of the
system row cm is just your classical
estimate for the density Matrix
and so what I'll call this thing uh
although you know it's not so well
motivated so far it will be next slide
um I'll call this thing the quantum
classical entanglement entropy
but the useful thing about the quantum
classical entanglement entropy isn't um
it's not that it necessarily tells us
anything so far it doesn't appear to
understand anything direct about the
quantum system
um the point is it appears as a
contribution to the quantum relative
relative entropy and so this is where we
get closer to ideas in um cross entropy
benchmarking so the quantum relative
entropy is defined in this way so this
first term here is minus the actual
entanglement entropy that we'd like and
the second part here is the Quantum
classical entanglement entropy that
we're able to extract in our experiment
so the point is that because the quantum
relative entropy is actually
non-negative
um this means that by cross-correlating
experimental data with the results of
our simulations it's actually possible
to find an upper bound on the true
measurement average entanglement entropy
um to add to this I'm sure I won't get a
chance I won't have time to talk about
this later you can actually also find a
lower band on the true measurement
average entanglement entropy so this
really gives you a way of inferring the
effects that the measurements are having
on the entanglement of a Quantum State
without having to post-select you just
need to have some simulation and these
simulations can be done after your
experiment
okay so the significance of this as
highlighted in bold here is that this
actually means that despite the fact you
can only see each post measurement State
once it's nevertheless possible to probe
physical quantities
so there's not this this game of
cross-correlating between your
expectation and what's really going on
in your experiment is not completely
artificial
another nice thing about the fact this
is a you know a bound on a true physical
quantity is it gives you the ingredients
for a variational scheme that you can
use to improve your models for your for
your Quantum system based on
experimental data that is to say I could
give you a set of measurement outcomes
and a set of Shadows row s and you could
then take a neural network or you know
something much more much simpler and try
to optimize your model for the quantum
system by minimizing this
average cross correlation
okay so if that seems a little bit
abstract I can talk about uh an
application and well I say an
application but I can talk about I talk
about an actual experiment you can do in
this way
um and the scheme I'll described is very
similar to what was implemented in the
Google experiment not long ago
so
um the physical sense that we can
imagine is you have a unit you have your
Quantum circuit and you're subjecting
your Quantum circuit to local
measurements
okay and these are the outcomes here
so these unitary gates are actually to
entangle the different qubits the single
qubit measurements are disentangling the
qubits
and now we know that and this is dual to
this transition in random circuit
sampling I was talking about before if
the measurement rate is sufficiently low
enough in this case the state will
remain highly entangled that is to say
you're revolving Quantum state is robust
to a finite finite space-time density of
measurements
on the other hand if you push your
measurement rate too high the state
becomes weakly entangled it falls apart
and ends up being efficiently simulable
so one way of viewing this entanglement
transition is really a transition
between states you cannot describe in a
classical computer and states that you
can
foreign so okay let's uh move back to a
probe like the one I was talking about
before let's imagine that after running
this Evolution for some time uh we
measure all of these uh all these qubits
in the middle and now we can ask having
measured all these qubits in the middle
what effect does this have on the
entanglement entropy of this qubit over
here that is to say has the state Fallen
apart or are we going to create a bell
pair between these two sides of the
system
so to check this we can use exactly the
scheme I just described where we take
one of these on one of these qubits at
the edge we apply a random unitary we
measure we extract a classical shadow
um I shouldn't call this a classical
Shadow because this is really the
quantum side of the quantum classical
cross correlation
um and the point is that for p less than
PC the boundary cubits remain entangled
that is to say you create a long-range
Bell pair with some fidelity
um so for p greater than PC on the other
hand you find the boundary Cube It's a
disentangle
so but what I'm going to be focusing on
over the next slide or so is the
critical point itself so really the
Threshold at which we can you know where
were the threshold where we're on the
edge of not being able to describe our
Quantum system
so at this point uh the entanglement the
entanglement entry of this qubit
actually decays as a power law of the
system size there's a kind of emergent
scaling variance
um and the classical memory that you'd
need to store the state at this
threshold we believe is just polynomial
in the system size we can represent it
with a matrix product state where the
bond Dimension is polynomial and system
size
um so yeah the question is now okay you
run up against this this threshold where
you can no longer do simulations
and you can ask how do your simulations
how do your simulations behave
so just to review
we evolve the quantum State we measure
the bulk key bits we extract a shadow
then our classical simulation now is no
longer going to be an abacus but um it's
going to be a tensor Network simulation
and a finite Bond Dimension Chi
as I was just saying the memory required
for the simulation is just polynomial in
the system size where B series some
exponent that I can mention in a moment
um we feed the outcomes into the
classical simulation
the classical simulation spits out this
classical estimate for the density
Matrix and from this we get our Quantum
classical entanglement entropy
now what we can do is average this
Quantum classical entanglement entropy
and ask how good which is our bound on
the true entanglement entropy and we can
ask how good is our bound
so this is when
um
some ideas developed maybe 14 15 years
ago now become useful
and this is to do with this uh okay if
we want to ask how our simulations
behave we can appeal some ideas from the
theory of finite entanglement scaling so
the point is that if you're at a
critical point if you have some system
with power locker with scaling variants
um then typically if you impose the
constraint of only using finite
classical memory this is going to
introduce some finite length scale this
finite length scale this correlation
length I'll call PSI and it was shown
back in 2009
um that this length scale typically
scales polynomially with the with the
bond dimension
so that theory find out finite
entanglement scaling is really what it's
doing here what it's doing is qualifying
the classical memory that you would need
to observe Quantum criticality on a
classical computer so they were thinking
about
um one-dimensional systems exhibiting
conventional Quantum phase stress it
transitions such as the one you see in
the transistoricalizing model for those
of you who are familiar with that or
that also occur pretty generically in
one-dimensional systems with particle
number conservation so one-dimensional
Quantum liquids
so what I'm going to be talking about a
slightly different kind of finite
entanglement scaling this isn't going to
be
um assessing the memory that's required
to observe your to observe interesting
effects on a classical computer what I'm
going to be talking about is the because
I'm talking about this Quantum classical
object I'm going to be trying to
quantify the classical memory that's
required to observe measurement induced
criticality on a quantum computer
um and remarkably a similar thing
happens so if you look at this Quantum
classical entanglement entropy you find
that it has a particular scale at this
particular scaling form so what I'm
showing on the right here is the the
setup I described before where I measure
the bulk qubits I determine the entangle
I try to Upper bound the entanglement
entropy of one of the edge qubits and I
ask how this entanglement entry behaves
with the system size and with the bond
Dimension now down here we're in the
kind of memory unlimited regime where
the system has not noticed that you're
working at finite classical memory
over here you see the kind of uh the
exact result your bound is very tight
and you see the expected power law decay
but then as the constraints of a
classical memory become more severe
while the true signal should keep going
down as a parallel forever your bound is
going to shoot off to something very
large and become you know a pretty poor
bound
um but the point is that the the way
that the simulation breaks down
um
is you can think of it as really a
signature of measurement induced
criticality so these are just some
numbers that aren't super important
um
but so the point is that what I've done
here is I've taken a number of different
Bond dimensions and system sizes and by
showing that there is this kind of uh
Universal Universal collapse of all of
this data uh you can see that there
really is a finite length scale
introduced to your Quantum classical
cross-correlation by the constraint of
classical memory
and yeah so given that given that any
probe of measurement induced phenomena
is ultimately going to involve a
classical simulation in some way this is
a a pretty sharp probe of what's going
on
okay so that's the
um that's the
an example of the kind of thing you can
observe using these cross correlations
uh in the last couple of minutes I'll
just flash through a few a few lines on
how you can also get a lower bound on
the entanglement entropy if you're you
know so if your aim is to characterize
the entanglement entry of a Quantum
State there's actually going to be a
physical setting in which you can
tightly determine the at the true
entanglement entropy
so what we're going to have to the the
game we're going to have to play here is
extending the scope of our investigation
let's not just look at that one
unmeasured qubit let's think about two
unmeasured qubits let's call these A and
B
so row M A B is the density Matrix of A
and B conditioned on the outcomes
elsewhere in the system and row c m a b
is our classical estimate for this
density Matrix
so the relative entropy of the region a
b is defined in this way all right okay
I can just write it in terms of the
quantum classical entanglement entropy
um and by by the monotonicity of the
entropy we know that this relative
entropy that is to say the difference
between our okay sorry I should unpack
what this means so dabm is quantifying
how different our classical estimate is
from the true density Matrix and this is
to say that the the difference if we you
know throw away some of the information
by restricting to just part of this part
of the system
um the the the you know the perceived
difference will be smaller
so distance entanglement entropies are
always greater than or equal to zero
this immediately implies that we can
also you can also get to this lower
Bound in the entanglement entropy
combining this with the thing I
described before we have both lower and
upper bounds on the entangle on the post
measurement averaged entanglement
entropy
uh and interestingly while the upper
bound here becomes tight and then a bit
of a perfect classical simulation
um if you have even even for a perfect
classical simulation you have to be a
bit careful about which physical
settings you look at so if it turns out
that you've prepared a pure State On A
and B then it's then you can both lower
and upper bound the entanglement entropy
otherwise you have some finite tolerance
except by this entanglement entropy
um but okay that sort of brings me to
the end uh so to summarize what I've
been talking about so I've been talking
about okay if you want to do an
experiment studying the effects of many
measurements in a Quantum system you
have to change what you uh mean by a
comparison between Theory and experiment
you can't just compare your theoretical
estimate with the experiment you have to
compare the cross correlation between
the two of them with your theory
I've shown that this is not a uh
completely artificial game because there
are certain ways that you can cross
correlate that allow you to bound system
uh system properties which do not depend
on the way you've chosen to model the
system
um and I think what you know what's
generally pretty interesting about this
setting is that it appears that you can
only really observe measurement induced
phenomena that you can also simulate
which raises a pretty interesting
question of whether a Quantum simulator
actually gives us very much when we're
trying to study measurement induced
phenomena
the outlook here
um is okay first off
um if that doesn't turn out to be uh if
it turns out the quantum simulators do
give you something Beyond classical
computers when studying the effects of
many measurements
um there are a number of new things we
can do we can study the phenomena like
those I just described we can study
something people call Deep
thermalization which is the um
I I kind of high a higher order form of
what people often call the eigenstate
thermalization hypothesis in quantity
statistical mechanics
um and something that I think would be
pretty interesting that we're thinking
about a bit now is whether you can use
uh variational methods to learn you know
efficient descriptions of
post-measurement quantum States even in
the setting where the pre-measurement
quantum state is quite complex so you
can imagine taking a highly entangled
mini body Quantum state that you can't
possibly store measuring it to decrease
its complexity and then asking whether
this classical information extracted
through measurement is enough to
construct an efficient model for the
unmeasured subsystem
okay that brings me to the end so thank
you for listening
[Applause]
please
do you understand there's any scale of
hypothesis
uh so in that regime the bond Dimension
is supposed to be scaling exponentially
with the system size
um so
let's see just for the purely classical
object over the quantum classical object
purely possible
oh so purely classical objects I mean
the numerics we've done so far indicates
that you know the as you increase the
bond Dimension not much is happening
because the bottom edges you require are
just so large
um that you're not converging
uh it's not clear right now we could
discuss we should discuss this a bit
more later but it's not something we
um thought too seriously about given
that we expected all the simulations to
break down there
[Applause]